introduce you guys in sukune is meant to
be the strongest Sorcerer of all time
but chapter 229 of the manga caused the
internet to turn against him with many
people labeling him as a fraud that's
why for this video I've brought in two
of the best Jiu Jitsu guys and YouTubers
zoning in in DJ miles to help me figure
out whether the fraud allegations are
true alright so to start things off I
guess the first question we need to ask
is what do you guys think it means for
him to be a fraud and why would he be
one I think this narrative mostly came
from refugees from my hero right because
like the community uh the Jiu Jitsu
Kaizen Community has grown so much over
the last couple weeks and I mean mainly
it's because Gojo has been unsealed of
course but I also feel like since my
hero has been falling off a lot of that
Community has come over to jiu jitsu
kaisen because it's like the new hotness
because like if you look on Twitter like
during the prime time of like chapters
and when the leaks are going released it
is so similar to what the my hero
Community was like and it was never like
that before
so I think it's really just this influx
of like new like fair weather fans to be
honest putting like the clown wig on
sukuna and saying that you know he's
like a fraud or whatever like fraud just
kind of has lost its meaning at this
point it's like if you don't do what I
like then you're a fraud that's
essentially what it's become but going
back to the original question why they
say sukuna is a fraud is because
he's overcoming Gojo
with using abilities and means that
otherwise aren't inherent to him and now
that he has been hit with infinite void
now he's summoned maharaga to take on uh
Gojo which is like you know end game
essentially like it's really hard to
overcome that so now that he has put
Gojo in like this almost check me
position I guess they're just upset
about it because it's like oh baharaga
isn't inherently yours so that means
you're a fraud you needed him to save
you and you can't win otherwise and it's
just nonsense to me I think this whole
fraud allegation is coming from a pure
power scaling thing right like if we
look at sukuna no 10 Shadows uh he was
the one who said from episode one right
or the first chapter I can defeat you if
I got my 20 fingers right that's it
Point Blank you know so now he's overly
prepared and you know megamy's body has
the 10 Shadows most likely going to use
yozuru's gift at some point right yeah
for sure so now it's kind of hard to
have that what-if scenario because the
truth of of the matter is we're not
going to get that it's not like sakuna
by himself is going to face Gojo and you
know this what-if scenario of of the
clash of the two Titans it's a bit
diluted and I think that's where people
are feeling kind of iffy about it but
you know the counter argument memes
aside it's like well
did any of you guys think he wasn't
going to use every Arsenal in his bag of
tricks right so he's overly prepared uh
for better and for worse and maharaga is
just one of those things
um you know in his uh you know in his
Arsenal I was wondering do you think
that in the Lost chapter he was almost
letting Gojo beat him in a way just to
build up this moment I think that the
way when we look at the fight from the
get uh from the beginning to where it is
now yeah it seems like all this was kind
of luring him in even at the risk right
like him taking the riskier option as
Gojo mentioned to be damaged for
maharaga to just basically adapt to all
of this yeah um now it's yet to be
determined what his curse technique is
and whether that was enough to you know
uh defeat Gojo by himself but regardless
it doesn't matter because that's not the
narrative we're getting now yeah that
question right there is where it all
comes back to like could he have beaten
Gojo if 10 Shadows were wasn't involved
at all like could he have done it I mean
you make the point that he hasn't shown
his full curse technique which is valid
because obviously he has the fire and
probably other stuff as well like we
don't know what's in his black box like
he could have so many more moves up his
sleeves that we've never seen before so
in theory yeah he might have still
beaten Gojo even without 10 Shadows but
the fact he's gone down this road it
implies that at the very least maharaga
is easier to beat godrej than using
tsukuna's own technique so if maharaga
wasn't in the equation would he have
still won is is a question that's hard
to answer at this point isn't it I think
he can for sure because he's already
beating him like he was beating Gojo
without using the 10 Shadows for most of
the fight so if he was if he didn't have
the 10 shadows and let's say he was like
still on YouTube's body or something it
would have been more difficult for sure
but I do think that he could have
defeated him because he's just better
than him he's out playing him in like
most of this match and I guess people
just don't like that because there's
more more Gojo fans I guess tsukuna has
got most of the small wins up until this
point but as a counter to that I would
say that Gojo he's been learning is the
fight's been going on because remember
like when his domain got destroyed by
the open barrier like he was taken by
surprise he didn't expect that to happen
and so like a bunch of his domain
expansions after that you know the big
one the small one that's just him
tinkering like figuring out what exactly
tsukune can do and how he can counter it
so I wouldn't say that's sukuna
dominating Gojo that's just Gojo trying
to learn like how exactly am I going to
overcome this yeah I agree it's uh it's
interesting looking at the fight where I
think sukuna overall is winning prior to
maharaga right but the Feats that Gojo
has done on the on the pushback has been
definitely more impressive
because a lot of people were questioning
you know that that first time when he
was caught in the The Domain expansion
and I still hope they address this why
didn't anyone tell Gojo about the
various domain in the first place like
this I I really knew that answered
because if it's not answered
it I don't know I don't want to say it's
a bit sloppy but well I think they could
have even told him because even when
like kanjaku did it and when Suka did it
last time when they did that no one else
had a domain inside that open barrier so
they didn't even know what would happen
really so even if they did tell him
would he have known that it would be
destroyed from the outside it's
impossible to say because yeah we've
literally never seen it
yeah yeah and this might be a little bit
of a weird analogy but I feel like the
way the story is going now even with
Gojo still being on uh on the defense
look this is gonna be like a like
wrestling right you can't have two of
the biggest you know Hulk Hogan and
Macho Man or whoever right be one-sided
so at some point even if Gojo's looking
bad and sakuna is winning you know uh
twirling his evil mustache I think
Gojo's still gonna come out and do
something extremely impressive defeating
maharaga or something else to that
nature uh and regardless of sukuna using
his real curse technique to get Gojo
yeah maybe sukuna could have beat him
without the 10 Shadows but we're not
gonna know that because he had to use it
and that was basically The Equalizer or
the deciding factor and all this when
it's said and done yeah it's just kind
of in a way it's just disappointing that
we'll never know for sure if he would
have won
um but in a way I guess this is cooler
though like seeing maharaga versus Gojo
I don't really think we would have got
that otherwise because I don't think
Mega me and Gojo would would have ever
been fighting for any reason so this is
really the only way we were gonna get
that so I guess it's worth it would you
say it's worth it just to see this 100
uh but also going back to like shakuna
defeating him otherwise it's like a lot
of another thing that like these fraud
people don't acknowledge is that sakuna
is at a disadvantage from the start he
always has been because he's never in
his true body never has 20 fingers is
never like in his like
complete comfort zone the way that Gojo
is
so if he was like full power 20 fingers
with the four arms in his normal body he
probably have an easier time defeating
Gojo to be honest but the fact that he's
always in somebody else's body not at
full power having to use their power set
and he's still winning I don't want to
say dominating but
he's like playing around him and winning
and everything and going back to what
you were saying about Gojo getting the
bigger wins I don't think he has at all
like him just blasting sukuna with a red
or whatever we don't even see it or
stabbing sukuna in the previous chapter
I think that's because sugunu wanted him
to do that like he wanted to get hit
with Limitless void he wanted him to hit
him with whatever he's doing to make him
think that he has the advantage here
because it even goes back to chapter 228
when like Gojo's questioning like yeah
he's using all of the abilities granted
by his domain but like why isn't he
using the 10 Shadows specifically
maharaga is because he was waiting he
always had the Dharma chakra like in the
shadows or whatever outside of Gojo's
grass I mean I guess he could see it
with the six eyes but he was like
adapting to things the whole time this
is all just like one calculated thing to
just break down Gojo one piece at a time
because he knew that he was eventually
going to use Limitless void and once he
got hit with it it was pretty much game
over at that point I mean I don't think
Gojo is like completely defeated of
course I'm sure he still has some tricks
up his sleeve but anyway I'm just trying
to say sakuna is not a fraud if anything
Gojo is a fraud he was like born with
the silver
Gojo is a frog because he's like he's
the embodiment of like the rich talented
like good looking like narcissist kid
that like he grew up with he's
essentially that so I I I think the
better question is now you know is he
going to get a second Awakening then
would you want a second Awakening from
Gojo the thing is if sukin has been
using the wheel since the very beginning
then that means he's adapted to
literally everything Gojo can do like
purple red anything Gojo can do he's
adapted to it so if Gojo doesn't have
another Awakening he's dead so um it
would be interesting to see maybe like
an open barrier from Gojo maybe that
would make a difference you know what
I'm thinking might happen do you do you
guys remember in like Dragon Ball super
when like Goku went Ultra Instinct
against jiren and like he basically beat
jiren and then Justice is about to deal
the finishing blow he collapses from
exhaustion he just like it hits him
right oh yeah I can see that happen I
think that might happen because the
nosebleed was the first hint of that I
feel like whatever's about to happen he
he's gonna beat maharaga somehow by
Awakening something or doing the maximum
and just when it looks like he's about
to win it just hits him and he's like
the exhaustion of using his curse
technique you know how many domain
expansions has he done like five at this
point
um yeah so and probably six soon in like
next couple chapters so yeah I think
that could happen like six domain
expansions back to back literally
breaking the world record here and then
just collapses after that as soon as
he's about to beat
um tsukuna so I think if that happens I
will definitely get more so you can a
fraud allegations for sure
um but but I think yeah that's that's
definitely possible so there's one thing
I want to make a real side tangent and
it's with kashimo right because I think
I saw a Creator talk about you know how
gay is very influenced with the whole
Buddhism and Hinduism and all that stuff
yeah and they were basically saying
kashimoto's like final attack it's based
off of this whole Buddhism mythology or
whatever where the final attack I guess
was catered toward the Buddhist analogy
of what sukuna is and that one final
attack like in Buddhist history or
whatever I'm butchering it but that
attack was actually specifically done at
the maharaga equivalent
so now I wonder if we get a 2V1 with
sukuna maharaga versus Gojo next chapter
or this is where costume I was like you
know what I'm just jumping in don't stop
me you know and now we get some crazy
2v2 action or kashmello somehow
intervenes in his final attack somehow
gets designated toward maharaga so Gojo
can face off against sakuna and then at
this point now the the fraud the fraud
allegations is going to be pinned on
both sides because now this isn't a 1v1
anymore yeah I mean I mean kashimo is
his cuss technique is like one time
cursed technique that definitely has to
come into play against sukhner in some
way
um because if it's I mean the whole
reason why kashimo saved that was
specifically for sukuna so if we were to
end this series with that never being a
thing would that be disappointing I feel
like maybe because it was kind of built
up as this thing specifically that could
take down tsukuna but uh we'll see what
happens with that anyway guys so just
before we wrap up the video I want to
hear your final conclusions is fraud yes
or no we'll start with you DJ miles what
do you think
I don't think he's a fraud but from the
power scaling fandom people will always
consider him to be a fraud and those
what if videos are going to be done
non-stop from now until the end of the
series
no he he's
he's at such a disadvantage and he's
still winning I don't like such a cool
way I take your point and they're like
four armsukuna is a different beast but
if I had the choice if I'm sukuna would
I rather be forearmsukuna or sukuna with
the 10 Shadows plus my originally
overpowered curse technique like I feel
like he's got the better end of the
stick to have 10 Shadows on your side
plus cleave dismantle the fire whatever
else I think like all of that is
probably better than if he was just in
his original form and that was it I
don't know I mean he just seems like
he's he he's still not at full power
regardless you mean like the one finger
that's still out there yeah but didn't
he conversate for that by eating like
there the head he ate the head but I
don't think that replaces a finger
because
like this finger has like a part of his
soul in it yeah I don't know but he
seemed to think so I don't know exactly
how it works have you guys heard the
theory that the one finger that's out
there nobra is going to come and like
use resonance on it have you seen that
one yeah
dude she's alive she's alive I'm telling
you show me the body show me the body we
did see it
that dead ass corpse with that eye
missing she's dead look I'm still a
noble believer okay they just give way
too many indirect hints about like
alluding to her to not bring her back
look and if she's dead she's dead I'm
just saying then why would they like
just uh you know shuffle around the fact
on whether or not she's dead you know I
I think she's still coming back like I'm
telling you like WWE style this is gonna
be like some crazy colon game like
appearance out of nowhere where all the
good guys are about to lose and boom
it's no bro with the iPads coming to see
you here you hear her music start
playing and then she starts running out
foreign
the crowd is screaming yeah yeah all
right guys well um thank you for coming
on the channel and just in case anyone
doesn't know who you are do you want to
say a few quick words about what you do
on your channel uh yeah so I'm uh
chainsaw man Jiu Jitsu Kaizen content
creator and uh yeah you can find me
talking about those two series don't
watch my channel don't subscribe just
subscribe to these guys this reverse
psychology this isn't the first time
I've seen you do that well on that note
don't subscribe to me guys wink wink
don't do it